une visite quasiment privé pour la
première matinée d'ouverture de france
miniature une centaine de personnes est
venue découvrir les grands monuments
français c'est à part qu'on affectionne
particulièrement on adore se promener
ici et comme bien peu de monde
finalement on n'a même pas besoin
d'avoir le masque parce qu'on peut très
bien se promener tranquillement sans
rencontrer grand monde ça se passe très
très bien c'est l'un de mes parts que
préféré c'est vraiment génial
il ya des petits traits partout c'est
super les enfants sont contents on peut
multiplier se balader comme on veut il
n'y a pas de problème de distanciation
on respire un peu on va dire des enfants
en fait il avait très envie de venir on
avait prévu d'y aller pour
l'anniversaire du grand qui était le 30
mars mais du coup comme c'était fermé
voilà donc dès leur ouverture on a dit
on y va on met les garçons au pied c'est
très contente que c'était une surprise
elle la reprise s'est donc fait tout en
douceur pour l'équipe du site élan
courtois les monuments n'avait pas vu
deux publics depuis le mois de novembre
c'était aussi une volonté d'ouvrir à
vendredi pour commencer sereinement et
doucement et dès ce week end je pense
qu'on va un petit peu plus de monde on a
quelques réservations en ligne
et puis notre communication vient d'être
lancée également jusqu'à la veille jeudi
25 juin les salariés peaufiner les
derniers réglages sur le pont depuis la
mi mai ils ont pris soin de la demeure
du roi soleil
alors il restait pas mal de choses
notamment sur versailles là
la fin de la restauration c'est une
maquette qu'on restaure en plusieurs
fois tel temps elle est grande
il ya à peu près 200 m² de maquettes sur
le parc donc on a fait en trois fois en
mars dernier l'élan de france miniature
est stoppé net par le confinement des
cds par l'état à deux semaines d'une
réouverture annuel les quinze salariés
permanents sont placés en chômage
partiel et les grilles restent closes
c'est évidemment très très impactant
pour france miniature qui accueille
chaque année deux cent mille visiteurs
et ça depuis trois ans on avait une
belle remontée de la fréquentation
depuis ces trois dernières années compte
tenu de toutes les nouveautés qu'on
avait installé quatre familiale enfin
qui répondait aux attentes de notre
public et ils sont ces trois mois de
l'ouverture et de nos ouvertures plus
exactement on a perdu près de cent mille
de nos visiteurs attendus accès
visiteurs et files d'attentes repenser
salariés supplémentaires pour veiller au
bon respect des consignes ou encore
espace fermé non accessibles france
miniature est ouvert tous les jours de
l'été un tour de l'hexagone en une seule
journée